vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui vous avez déjà
un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'ils derrière la
console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités dans la cité
h quentin avec mois de novembre on est
ici même en temps de pandémie on a pris
toutes les recommandations nécessaires
on a désinfecté nos petits mof
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas un mois au
moins n'ont pas ouvert vous cette jeune
homme
le sans fil des prochains débats par un
gore 29 une entreprise québécoise une
boutique de linge et ont plus de
cinquante boutiques au québec un petit
peu partout même nouveau brunswick et
ils ont donné ces magnifiques morceaux
comme vous pouvez voir ce beau petit
bonheur ce beau petit chandail vert
forêt si vous n'écoutez juste en audio
en ce moment
vous irez voir à gaz sur puis sur
youtube vous verrez comment qu'on est
amis way est également une boutique en
ligne sur laquelle vous pouvez allez y
vous allez avoir avec le code promo 15
15 15 % de rabais leur siège social est
basé à rimouski comme existe des
entreprises locales qui encourage aussi
les marques locales l'axé c'est le fun
ils sont également très impliqué pour la
fondation la fondation vagabond qui aide
les femmes victimes de violence
conjugale et violences faites aux femmes
en général
et puis allez sur la scène musicale est
en ligne et vous serez pas déçus ont
vraiment du bol âge nous ont été
recueillis accueilli en fait comme des
rois là bas je suis allée puis frédéric
qui était leur mode année les morceaux
de mon choix puis j'ai vraiment la
meilleure chose parce qu'il met trop de
trop de belles affaires c'est ce pas
parfois nous super h comme pouvoir fidel
et
et vraiment ça se fait qu'une entreprise
à découvrir une boutique à visiter si
vous connaissez pas déjà
je vous encourage à tickets ce hangar 29
yes puis le podcast semaine est
également présentée par monsieur chalet
si vous écoutez pas de cash money que
vous savez en ce moment que fadasse
total sic j'ai fait occupation double
depuis que j'ai pas gagné occupation
double pis que le gagnant d'occupation
double d'un chalet qui est gérée par
monsieur chalet donc monsieur chalet ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils louent des
chalets luxueux dont le chalet d'amour
gagnant d'occupation double ben ali veut
aller sur leur site web chez qu'en ce
moment les voyages comme la plupart à
l'eau pour des raisons qui sont très
envieuse en ce qui nous concerne donc
vous allez pouvoir reprendre vos
vacances durant l'été parce qu'ils ont
plein forfait qui sans rien durant l'été
fait qu'aller voir sur leur site ils ont
plus de 400 choix de chalet luxueux
partout québec pis pour être allé dans
certains leur chalet pour plusieurs
raisons c'est vraiment de la bombe
donc c'est vraiment des chalets de luxe
vous pouvez les lacs des amis vous allez
là avec vos amoureux et amoureuses pour
revivre un week end romantique
bref toutes les raisons sont bonnes pour
louer des chalets chez monsieur chalet
puis en plus c'est du monde sont
vraiment smart je connais
personnellement fils qui le coupe on
attendait depuis est vraiment cool donc
allé voir sur leur site web où vous
pouvez même réserver par téléphone donc
allé voir sur monsieur chalet donc c'est
ça sinon cette semaine cette semaine on
a su cassandre bouchard qui est une
créatrice de contenus influenceurs sais
pas ce que vous voulez sur youtube et
sur les instincts g
on a parlé un petit peu de c'est quoi la
vie d'être un influenceur comment elle
s'est manifestée commencé c'est arrivé
dans sa vie et en rapidement le prix un
petit
tangente un petit peu plus émotionnel
dit peux nous parler des relations elles
qui qui qui malheureusement est la peine
ces temps ci est en tentant séparation
alors abordé le sujet est aussi la cause
cette opération qui est quelque chose de
décommander difficile alors vous allez
voir qu'on consiste conscrits stion
beaucoup sur les relations en général
c'est une belle conversation je pense
qu'on s'est tous écouté ouvert et y
compris et ils supporter que ça bah
ouais c'est ça qui est vraiment superbe
au podcast avec les cassandres une belle
découverte encore une fois pièce puis
l'enfant ont laissé les commentaires
participer aux discussions comme
toujours laissé de time's up partout et
ce que vous l'écoutez parlez-en aux amis
dans un temps de pandémie tout le monde
recherche contenus gratuits sur internet
puis cisco offre donc sans plus attendre
bompas pia
bonne écoute
[Musique]
samba à la bossa des carottes et m
triple oui les charges sur la santé
cette voile des contrats mais t'es tu
t'habitues d'attendre d'avoir ce genre
de l'espèce de bosses des stigmas mois
dégueulasses constantin non je pense que
j'aime ma voix on allait sur cinq au
risque mais c'est pas ça mais comme dans
une bulle ouais on est comme les trois
nuls ouais on ne tue pas la première
fois qu'on s'est vus sortait juste dos
des tarifs était allé faire un tour née
de friperie et que j'ai su attaquer je
travaillais pour la wes est ce parce que
dans le fond mais en deux ans tout avion
quand même changé pas mal fait king ses
droits sacrés on ne brûle mais ouais
effectivement à ce moment là je me
rappelles tu commences une chaîne
youtube pente n'était pas commencer
maintenant moi c'était vraiment je
faisais les capsules pour moi aussi you
to save
ça fait même pas 2 en fait pour
l'instant c'est quand même techniquement
oui mais ça va exploser complètement
notre enfant mais on dirait que je pense
que quand tu es dedans tu t'en rends pas
vraiment compte
mais c'est vrai que je suis vraiment
reconnaissant de chance résister c'est
sûr ça a augmenté quand même vraiment
vite comment je vis des tissus et qui
peut peut être plein c'est vraiment
surtout après avoir travaillé
gratuitement pour marc citti parlant
comme un élan ouais c'est sûr des
collaborateurs comme ceux qui le font
gratuitement peau pour créer quelque
chose je me dis je comme si j'ai
travaillé gratuitement mais ça m'a
apporté quelque chose quand même
du coup vrai quoi on sait que deux
articles plus qu'il veut honnêtement
j'ai en fait je trouvais pas d'article
c'est comme animatrice devant la caméra
baptiste est un nouveau département
aussi puis c'est comme moi qui le lancer
avec eurent fait
au début on disait on n'a pas de budget
pour ça vu que ces nouveaux ce que je
comprenais mais comme enfin on a eu des
contres payant plus qu'acheter commencer
un peuple wê geste m'a donné un petit
bouquet chez les capsules pillet
d'enfants je me sentais un peu comme
genre de guide touristique de montréal
ouais je sais un peu plate pour se
hisser comme juste la fille qui comme
faisaient de découvrir montréal passe
concernant marc citti à la baston pu se
défaire des articles sur montréal
oui exact exact fakty j'ai vraiment
commencé comme ça pas mal et je me suis
un peu écoeuré de faire ce genre de
contenu comme je prends une guide
touristique thanvillé mais samedi
quelque chose de plus à apporter qui te
faire découvrir un bon petit café site
succès cette réflexion les imagine qui a
propulsé adjamé je dois faire ma propre
affaire
ouais je t'ai carré que le monde me
reconnaissent comme étant la fille de
marc citti tester un public restreint
dans mon contenu qui je me détends qu'à
travailler gratuitement
je travaille on va travailler pour moi
gratuitement les facs et ce je me suis
dit tu es avec youtube je pensais pas
faire et l'argent ne dort jamais faire
de l'argent je pense qu'on commence sur
youtube ce qui est tant mieux mais je me
suis dit fuck off mais start une chaîne
youtube je vais faire mes affaires je
dois apprendre aussi parce que tu es qui
bougeait a pris en photo montage faire
tout cela fait que ce je suis vraiment
content de l'avoir fait d'abord fokine
blanchi narcisse 6 pi 1 po maintien on
s'entend que ça prend un certain temps
avant qu'ils puissent monétiser de se la
faire le psy de travailler pour nasty
gratuitement qu'est ce que tu faisais
qu'est ce que tu faisais jeunes que
c'est sûr qu'il y paraît mais c'est le
fun la presse inquiète et carys en
tabarnak de travail de temps ça permet
je peux même avoir d or qui sont pas si
si lourdes c'est payant km hors
ajustements qui me permettait de pouvoir
faire ce que je voulais faire dans la
vie on décèle même si je connais pas ma
vie à mes côtés ces jours faux king tort
de georges fenech a commencé à 4 heures
herman déclencher si ça hypothèque ou si
ta journée du lendemain après cette date
aucune créativité était juste un zombie
qui se leva genre deux heures de
l'après-midi pixar a rien d pu être
agent big star i way servir est
désavouée il faut quand on y pense était
venu chercher jesse pillet ouais c'est
après ouais
oui mais oui c'est moi c'est ça c'est ce
qui fait que je trouvais coup l'enfant
de te recevoir puis de pouvoir faire
l'espèce de panoramas de ton historique
jusqu'à là parce que j'étais je trouve
vraiment que ça le comme maintenant tu
es dans le paysage pièces de créateurs
de contenu québécois lundi puis ça fait
pas ça fait drôle mais c'est vraiment
cool de voir comme l'évolution complet
en si peu de temps c'est comme rentrer
dans ce cirque l'oeil j'imagine que
aquana kwacha tributes honda croissance
rapide dont on appelle ça comme ça
s'écoute on sai récents semblent avoir
fait correctement sur notre âme sans me
voir maintenant si j'avais à pointer
quelques affaires loin semble à
quelqu'un ou qui est apprécié par les
gens du milieu
enfin effectué peut faire des
collaborations avec les gens du mieux
fait que c'est vraiment une bonne façon
qu'imagine 2 40e tellement je parle de
sujets qui sont pas abordées beaucoup tu
parle de sexualité sait qui est qui et
on y reviendra tantôt lemay qui prenant
la chose que les gens cliquent le plus
soin mater c'est sûr je suis vraiment
curieux puis vraiment on est dans mon
fils est bassiste et la troisième phase
oui mais c'est vrai que faire des
collaborations c'est sûr que 100% salle
augmenter mon following rapidement puis
je le recommande à tout le monde qu'ils
me sens et sur youtube
lachance l'opportunité tu connais
quelqu'un c'est motivant aussi parce que
là
va prendre des affaires par rapport à
cet effet une collab avec une personne
ça fait huit ans qui est sur youtube a
été comme je sais pas tu apprends
tellement moi j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
enrichissant mais oui je pense que c'est
une bonne question
en fait quand je me suis jamais posé ces
questions là mais je pense que ça serait
vraiment par rapport à mon nom mon
authenticité
l'effet que je m'en contrefous si je
pose vraiment n'importe quoi je poserai
- comme qu'est ce que j'ai envie de
poster tes jamais je me pose la question
est ce que je devrais est ce que je
devrais un poster ça ou est ce que je
devrais pas le post et issus comme j'ai
envie de faire ça je la fêterais est ce
que dans tout ce processus là déjà pris
des décisions basées sur la réception
que ça allait avoir au sens où est ce
que ta job et ont décidé de farah qui
n'ont le consciemment je veux faire une
collaboration pour la croissance de mes
enfants je pense pas consciemment
non non vraiment pas j'ai jamais voulu
profiter d'être sao profiter des gens de
leur fort lobbying vraiment paul je
pense que c'est apple choc sa famille
bref c'est lisa non vraiment pas mais
c'est sûr que comme tu es mettons les
premières collaborations que j'ai fait
sur ma chaîne la première collaboration
j'ai fait avec gamme marion depuis c'est
moi j'ai voulu faire un coup là-bas avec
cap parce que je trouvais qu en tant que
personne et en tant que nos
personnalités fuite est vraiment acté j
écris puis comme ça t'en trait dessus je
me rappelle ensemble je pense j'avais
comme peut-être 7 mai la bonité ce qui
est quand même quelque chose pour versus
elle aurait tellement pu faire comme
ceux qui s'étaient d'obbadi le qui
m'écrit t elle aussi ça a été la même
chose ça a été une question de feeling
si on s'est rencontrés avant est allé
prendre une guerre c'était vraiment cool
et je pense que ça je veux je veux avant
tout les jours je veux qu'on soit à
l'aise parce que je trouvais ça paraît
de façon saine colère avec quelqu'un
peut-il vraiment pas confortable
c'est juste que c'est des vrais amis le
vends car je t'aimerai bas n'ont
vraiment pas été offert
ça a commencé comme ça puis au final tu
es je les compte parmi mes très bons
amis
ça a été la même chose avec noémie
lacerte avec marie gagner tu sais c'est
motivant aussi de s'entourer de gens qui
font la même chose que toi très sexy
mais suivent et transcontinentaux il
faut aussi juste et le monde deux fois
cela écrit pour demander ça de temps
dessus oui ça se passe jamais comme tu
dis aux gens je lance une perche
ça peut marcher peut-être pas peut-être
à nancy n'a pas marché aussi à man des x
demande la porte un nom facile comme le
pick up elvis tenons le mode je rappelle
tim et aucun cas qu'on sortait d'un bar
mettons stores blessés a constaté qu'en
même temps tu es petit tu es dans le
conte est donc un sacré challenge j25
way fait que l'acheteur bord de tenir
son histoire ben ouais ouais ouais ça
tape ça t4 dit je sais que le pire qui
peut arriver si je veux voir cette file
le pire qui va agresser qu'à votre dire
non ouais mais c'est quand même un nom
qui quittent offre un chien c'est ainsi
nous tiens si à l'hippodrome et outils
si halak c'est pas ton message tu verra
même pas qui est qu'elle lui l'éthique
mais la ccam annonce ça peut être
effectivement c'est dire qu'ils en
parlent du monde et technique entre aux
soirées incroyables la souris entre
guillemets des stars chicks on l'appelle
comme ça l'a rencontré un groupe de
filles à ce que mes os tarbes à artix
[Rires]
histoires comme ça que mon parti de
notre folklore comme on sait que ce soir
le plus important on parle à tout le
monde
puis on n'est pas au top teams et on
sait pas naturellement ton pour nous
autres les polygones place piquionne
comme c'est facile d'accès comme acquis
lorsque leur bateau le 10 à 18h 19h et
sa classe technique encore plus tôt oui
je sais ça fait dix adhérents du vieux
oui mais non est radieux est ce que vous
avez à vous allez avoir 31 ans
prochainement en janvier prochain
bonjour 29 le state l'été prochain ça 30
mais elle continue excuse moi mais je me
suis fait un petit détail mais c'est
vraiment le temps titrant des rencontres
on n'a parlé que ça l'était au début
tout d'habitat proches qui ont appelé à
la com sont ces personnes là comme son
bouclier
les places perce le bouclier pleuve
d'amendé civile
on sort du bas qui font que j'en ai qui
se pètent dans la soie dégâts fait le
bas rien
aubin voulez-vous venir chez nous c'est
la première et dernière
ja on passe près de chez eux jean-pierre
on passe une soirée est certain à 90% à
wii fit avec comme des pilules malheur
d'être dans un sac ziploc le puits puis
en mai comme une fille qui n'a mis une
dent bière de file file s'en est rendu
compte et commercial puis un petit peu
après lui à passer le convoi willis
détail le match en main mais si j'avais
une amie le cake gens qui avaient des
livres de jardin qui appelait ses libres
pisi genre sismiques sont comme avait
dit que c'était si beau 2020 céderait
2008 c'était genre déjà faut que tu
dises les filles avant de leur parler le
titulaire fin trop compliments d'après
ce que tu leur donnes météo bas mais
tant elle salue plus l'oeil aperçu le
beach shield et que tu arrêtes ton bicho
dans le fond fait que maintenant moi je
tu abordes pied à quel point peut on
peut se moquer du monde et tout ça et
bien c'est en pole à qui s'était tue un
choix c'était un choix penser ses bottes
le baca - pourquoi que ça morde bains
sont bien voilà c'est tmc qui s'est fait
que tu fais quand un peu de désamorcer
la situation mais là je fais ce riz
qu'on commémore les techniques si on n'a
pas ces pratiques
on le voit mais ça marche pour survivre
loge pas pratiquer la chute des cours en
ligne
mais si cet appel aux preneurs mais
steam et on salue ça vaut c'est comme
pas cela comme un peu nos gens enfin les
crampes et en valais comme saïd un cash
prize de quoi déjà
ouais c'est ça va d'un vie qu'un train
quand quelqu'un c'est fois qu'une plate
la côte ouest est oui mais oui la
personne n'avait jamais de nom justement
merci demandé ça vaut
ouais j'ai la gioia bien qu'ils m'ont
fait sur quelqu'un et puis après ça j'en
ai reparlé pays maudit est une démarche
consciente maintenant qu'il y avait de
prendre un temps de répondre pour vrai
salut ça va plus il me regarde
il fait aujourd'hui c'est pas une si
bonne journée complètement déstabilisé
au japon n'avait pas le temps de
m'asseoir puis de francky pourquoi la
question si pourquoi tu le poser mais
parce qu'on pourrait poser n'importe
quelle occasion m mais si ce n'est pas
fait aujourd'hui outils maison mais
c'est le chemin métier quand t'as pas le
temps les 4-10 salut ça va je n'ai pas
le temps je savais pas d'eau pas le
temps d'y penser qu'une règle sera d'une
formule de déco toi c'était politesse
les salles us a voté il ya des places
dans le monde des cultures août
m'adresse à vous oh non mais je pense
pas mais ton coeur il faudrait faudrait
que nos auditeurs nous nous trouvons
auditeurs français comment je pense pas
qu'en france la le savon yayi qui
penserait que le savent au fond ça vaut
facilement classement ça vous salut ça
va je pense pas que c'est comme comme un
jeu mais ça doit passer à un de mes
meilleurs moments de podcasts depuis
qu'on fait le podcast avec annick de
martino qui ne comptait pas y aller chez
la psy mais par un poteau puis il
parlait pas mais j'aurais dit également
fermé meti l'épaule ça l'aidera mentaux
il y avait besoin mais il avait besoin
il souffrait pas un qui plaît le plus
c'est ça aussi ça lui yannick oui ça
vaut oui
nan mais à votre wave euros et non mais
est ce que ça vaut pis le avait fêté
juste poser ces questions là encore et
encore jusqu'à tant qu'à manille agents
explosifs puis c'est bon c'est fou ça
excuse moi aussi j'aimerais ça tombait
jamais vu jamais jamais jamais mais bien
ça fait 2 mois
ouais puisqu'il faisait 5 1 ça fait 5 1
mondial à sion oui c'est fou c'est fou à
quel point je pense qu'on réalise pas à
quel point qu'on s'identifie en coupe si
je dirais je sais qu'une personne je
sais que des trucs à apporter dans le
monde est en cassandra mais comme quand
ça fait autant en tant que tu avec une
personne c'est que c'est vous c'est
moins sûr si on soin si c'est exact fixé
merci oui c'est tout le temps on fixe
sur ce spécial de me retrouver seule 1
disons tout appris autant puis mois
avant les taxes à gorée ça faisait trois
ans et demi qu'elle était avec un autre
gars pas que ça fait quand même huit ans
dans ma vie technique était toute seule
et longue tige et 25 en fuite mais
dernière d'être le mois pour rester au
secondaire s'il est d'accord sur msn
brigade et gauche
comment ça va sa baisse à vos amis et à
vos amis
ouais t'as votre mieux qu'il ya deux
mois je commence à m'habituer
on s'entend tj s'apprend fois j'avais
tout seul aussi factice c'est spécial
mais c'est plus sur les réseaux sociaux
on dirait que j'ai des mesures en ce
moment n'ont vraiment pas ce que tu est
une personne justement vraiment comme on
est surtout ce que l'egypte eut
tellement je m'en fous de la dui mérité
vu que c'est moi qui ai fait une erreur
sur ma séparation je me sens mal de ne
pas me sentir bien en fait fait moi ça
ressemble bloc sur ce que je vis sur ce
que je dois montrer puis gelé comme
réalisé cette semaine que andré je me
sens justement moins créative - là à
cause de soucis que tu doutes sans mal
le pote sentir bien je mets en fait et
je me sens mal de montrer son est plate
forme qu'est ce que je vis pour vrai
parce que c'est moi qui a fait une
erreur dans mon couple en ce moment
noyer dans mon couple j'ai vu plein
coûte montrent que la cause de moi en
fait qu'on est plus compact et je me dis
gfg comme j'ai assumé sa au grand public
ce qui est des jeunes chose en soi que
j'ai quand même genre par leurs prix je
leur ferai mais d'autres et notre
relation peut-être que tu cadre est ce
plus ou privés bonnet semble je me
questionne à dessus vraiment que parce
que c'est foutu montrer que c'est une
chance de montrer ta vie de montrer tes
amis démontrer les personnes qui font
partie des victimes en attend
certainement ma mère à votre toujours
dans ma vie ça m'étonnerait crise
qu'elle soit comme un casse ça me tente
peut-être on s'entend mais une relation
si c'est comme c'est tellement personnel
petite cité par but ça peut être fragile
qui est vraiment des open days qui
demain je trouve ça difficile de trouver
ma ligne entre ma vie professionnelle et
ma vie personnelle ans pour moi je suis
comme dans un espèce de combat intérieur
par rapport à ça c'est vraiment la vidéo
que j'ai faite par rapport à ce débat
comme kim comme sonné la cloche je
voudrais parce qu'avant je m'étais
jamais posé la question de mon monde
j'aime ce dessein car on est ensemble
puis
c'est parti mon avis fait que je me
disais si je veux donc partagés sur les
plateformes mac avons vécu ce kit et
c'est une chose à partager les bons
côtés d'une relation sur des plateformes
et caen qui activent des affaires
négative ou comme tu es dans un data
relation où justement tu fais quelque
chose fait une grosse erreur c'est une
honte sur vous mettons vraiment moi j'ai
eu cette réflexion l'année en herbe ont
gagné un mandat c'est toute notre
relation oui avec ma copine a été devant
le dans l'oeil du public de l'année
notre première rencontre est ce que vous
sentez obligé de vous exposer au début
oui jusqu'à tant qu'à ramener on a une
pause plutôt énorme a piqué lobe parce
qu'on avait un dante mettons dans notre
relation lors seraient des messages par
centaines de comme un nouveau perso
pourquoi vous êtes persan si quoi que je
pense
puis quand ses revenues après ça je me
suis dit c'est pas ça regarde personne n
est pas nécessaire regarde personne même
si ça me donne plus de leur camp qu'on
fait une photo à deux même si la
compétence théorie le monde la regarde
plus même si tout ça ma relation intime
regarde personne d'autre que nous deux
ouais puis une fois que j'ai fait ça ça
ne change pas mal mais médias sociaux
lève moins qu'il veut je m'en rends
compte mais je suis très heureux avec
eux puis des fois tu vois du monde
je n'ai vraiment pas nommer non mais je
veux jouer du monde ces réseaux sociaux
qui ne vivent que pour la relation bien
ce n'était pas ce que c'est
je comprends que c'est bon pour les
réseaux sociaux parce que c'est cute
parce que c'est bon c'est bon au fond
mais en même temps que moi c'est un
exemple à part parce que parce que le
mmm ont connu que chacun connaît mon
aimée parce que ça s'est fait
naturellement
mais mettons dans ton cas toi
il ya eu un gros switch quand même parce
que il n'y avait pas de médias sociaux
au début de votre relation
non non c'est fx et comme c'est arrivé
j'ai eu quelqu'un là dedans qui est pas
dans we fêter ses 100 cas les réseaux
sociaux renaît et prennent de plus en
place dans ma vie c'est ça que ça a été
ça crée des conflits avec mon ex
ce que je trouve normal au sipi mais
j'avoue que c'est spécial c'est moi j'ai
rencontré cède avant de faire mais c'est
sûr que comme tu es ce que je vais avoir
un autre show man et dans ma ville je me
le souhaitent ce n'est pas tant qu'il
était le baht a toute ma vie il devrait
jouer en chantant c'est sûr que je vais
me poser plus de questions et je
l'exposerai ce que je n'expose pas dit
je pense qu'il va prendre moins de place
mais ça dépend vraiment de lui aussi
envie d'être exposée non puis celle du
salut revient puis après c'est aussi
s'aimer tons riches peuvent choquer
demandes qui sont faux la grèce lors des
runs héros de leur vie privée puis pitou
témoins deux personnes comme ce genre
les deux sont des jets toujours ce genre
t'as pas besoin de faire ce que l'autre
fait parce que c'est bon pour vous
jusqu'à ce que ce qui est plate aussi
c'est que quand tu exposes ton couple
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est kaman et
tu dis que tu dois quelque chose aux
gentils comme moi avec ma séparation si
je me sentais tellement pour vrai de
paul-duez puis comme j'ai fait une vidéo
que je dis clairement ce que j'ai fait
mais comme simone sur instagram sur
toutes les plateformes je me sens avant
le moment que j'en ai parlé je me
sentais tellement mal de dépôt avouer
que j'ai pu avec des mets au fond
stx à regarde personne c'est comme une
personne normale qui est en couple et
qui se séparent
c'est oui au persil sépare sur facebook
ou gentils sont ses amis sa famille vont
être au courant mais comme ça s'arrête
pas dans l'autre il s'agit vraiment
frappant moi je trouve ça je trouvais ça
tellement spécial de 1 vivre moi même
une séparation de deux devoir laver vos
grands jouent pas à ma communauté et où
j'ai vraiment j'ai pas aimé le monde
devient commentateur way
les gens sont tellement intrigué sont
tellement curieux puis virtuellement
tout savoir plus
j'étais tout leur donnent ce qu'ils
veulent quant au fond tu as déjà été ce
match parce qu'au fond tu dois rien à
personne
techniquement c'est moi qui dit kim qui
pense que je dois quelque chose aux gens
mais au fond je dois rire ou chanter les
gens vous suivent un peu comme ti avec
aude et puis l'après haut débit toi
comme si vous étiez des téléromans une
certaine façon le train entre auto beam
est on est animateur qu'elle est c'est
complètement différente c'est moi j
frappeurs permet aussi par rapport à ça
parce que c'est les alimentent atterri
dispo nécessairement tout leur ville sur
leur plateforme où dormaient les
chanteurs ne s'est pas récemment qu
est-ce qui vivent eux personnellement et
puis au double c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment des gens qui partagent leur vie
j'en serais heureux vivent mais comme
des fois et stx ajouts sont sur la
personne d'autant cette donnée parce que
j'ai menti c'est sûr vraiment faut
sûrement que ça devienne en fait
baklouti faisait en fait on impose
dernièrement sur terre ou en ifans de
2,10 andrew est ce qu'ils disaient eux
ils disaient que lui il sentait qu'il y
avait une pression de tout dévoiler plus
il faisait un peu le la métaphore avec
les photos nues ou en chef lui disais
tiens maintenant mon fils et ces deux là
sauf ponts-de-cé m'ont fait d'instagram
ces deux là sauf points si instagram
accepter les mamelons ce serait de la
politique
puis il disait j'ai de la misère à avec
cette pression là de dire faut que tu te
dévoile tout autant plein prenait
justement cet exemple précis physique
pour expliquer les plus largement de dia
faut que tu demandes démontre tout
puis le monde s'attendait à ce que
dévoile tout est dit avec cette idée
l'idée que ça devienne un espèce de
dijon obligé de montrer ma vulnérabilité
nom du personnage pas obligé de faire ça
tout le monde s'attend à ce que de la
monde mais je peux aussi montré quand ça
va juste bien ça se pourrait se montrer
positif qu'a mangé comme une frustration
par rapport à ça je termine un peu sur
les réseaux sociaux puissent comme un
peu un combat que je vis moi personnel
j'ai envie de montrer des facettes de
moi fucking dégueulasse j'ai envie que
le monde qui me suivent se sentent pas
inférieure à moi j'ai envie que les gens
soient comme assez casse est tellement
normale et elle aussi elle avec ce lice
pour ça que j'ai dit mais tant que j'ai
trompé mon ex parce que comme ça si pas
la seule touchée par réinventer la roue
le jeu pas la seule personne au monde
qui a trompé
risma pour le fait que t'as pas
justement si le fun je me débrouille
mais oui c'est que c'est si tel
manquement
bonjour la majorité du monde vont soit
dans leur vie avant d'aller tromper ou
et trompait déjà confrontés à cette
situation à un moment de leur vie tes
fac mais pour se rendre et je sens le
besoin de montrer le lait de moi mais
pas juste le lien intime et on les
facettes de moins vulnérables des
facettes de moi qui se lèvent le matin
qu'il faut king cole qui a des crottes
des yeux jusqu'à 10 des lentilles j'aime
j'ai besoin d'être seul mais comme je
comprends que pour une personne je
comprends que tu peux te poser la
question de ce qu'est ce que je veux
vraiment montrer j'en sais quoi que je
veux ce que je préfère jouer justement
moi montrer comme le boat mavi moi ce
que je suis plus à l'aise là dedans
comme plj ce qui est qu avec mon
collègue mais montrait que je me
sentirai je vais pas tomber dans
l'aspect un peu vendre du rêve sur
instagram sais vraiment pas ce que je
veux moi c'est pour mon instagram
moi je veux que le monde qui me voient
qu'ils quittent chèque mais à faire des
choses comme à saint fait normal qui vit
des trucs normalité de la vie et
équitation tir sur youtube il ya plus
qu'une sorte de contenus le temps du tpl
ce qui fait c'est plus divertissement
des jours ou des délits ici des sites
qui sont tous genre de challenge sexy
podor j'ouvre mon coeur puis je braille
la caméra puisque vainqueur avec pull et
un soutien public peau au plein
d'affaires peut-être qu'un état grave il
ya peut-être plus un genre de voici la
formule pour que ça lève le bain je sais
pas le sens tu ce nom qu'ils aient
jamais senti ça vraiment peu genre moi
je me rencontrer je pense des belles
photos aussi le vote au moins jusqu'à
l'été je pose des belles photos je pose
des photos avec ma famille avec montée
mais
je me suis jamais questionner m'a
demandé qu'est ce qui pose plus ce
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent - et ce qu'ils
m'ont fait des tas c'est beau est ce que
si au moins est ce que je devrais post
history lot et yacef aucune pompe est
sur la chine où puis-je décide faire une
tournée des annonces se serait dit
d'être plus tard quinze fois qu on n
était peut-être un peu trop pompette
pour faire une moi je m'en foutais rien
puis je m'en fous des caisses qui pose
plus ce qu'est ce qui peut monter enfin
fouet c'est une bonne question je trouve
justement c'est quoi la recette ni rock
pour un style de plusieurs films avec
son propre au public qui qui qui suit
lui doit ses demandes pour tout enfant
suffit que ce soit fait en bonne place
oui ça passe vraiment quelqu'un qui
fournit sa ceinture puis après je te
tout l'a dit que le penchant de ben beau
dire si on a beau dire que
l'authenticité façon une belle façon de
fonctionner mais après ça tu as comme
les effets en lingerie avec les seins
refaits pilée à ski qui ont des millions
d'abonnés même si personne les caennais
au québec le oui il y en a plusieurs des
québécoises qui sont au dessus de 1000
doté d'un million que personne n'a
jamais entendu parler parce qu'ils
préfèrent les 120 julie coin qui en a
vraiment beaucoup
puis ils se rassemblent toutes les
méthodes sont l'impression qu'il faut
sauver les photos sont tellement modifié
ou il ya tellement eu de chirurgie de
l'altération qui ont dit que comme une
espèce d'idéal instagram que je tends
vers ce pillon tout comme un visage a
même comme moi n'est pas sain crayeuse
la frustration voire cela on fait comme
il ya un moment où est ce que mon ex
genre il voulait montrer qui ils
voulaient que karima bona plainte contre
des films étaient faux lent chez mais
comparé à ce qu'il faut comme d'estoril
vidéo oui exact était comme c'est
pourquoi j'ai encore une fille c'est
folklo depuis georges jeune femme a
vraiment crée de la frustration je
t'aime des abonnés toutes ces
contributions et je pu rien savoir je
veux rien savoir de ces contrats
pourraient puis témoin jeune fille de 25
ans qui est sensiblement bien dans ma
peau
je me dis si sa crise et c'est justement
ce qui qui se compare tout le temps puis
tout c'est pour ça que je comme à ça me
semble vraiment pour ce que c'est méthon
mettons que tu allais voir un
scientifique de la santé physique
oui oui probablement qu'il
recommanderait de faire un genre de de
training autant musculaire et cardio
tient un petit peu de tapis roulant un
petit peu de haut du corps le bas du
corps j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans
une culture où est ce que c'est une
feuille tu fais du a dû quitter des yeux
du jury connaissent là où est ce que je
m'entraîne si je dirais que nous finir
ce cessez de tout le monde de tous les
genres de personnes qui viennent 75% du
temps quand je vois le fai a fait du à
6,75 pour ça le jeu puis prendre le
manque c'est juste par l'image qu'on se
fait de caisse qui a un corps de femme
doit peut-être oui mais ça c'est sûr
s'est perpétuée par les réseaux sociaux
le téléviseur
il y aurait bien des princes ta g que le
à ce jeu pourrait s'amorcer dans l'ombre
les plus graves je pensais pas normal
twinning soins que tu as comme ça pas de
sens la personne sur commun c'est
l'équivalent d'un gars qui veulent juste
faire des bises ce point mettez mettons
moi honnêtement jpod à sedan vie j'ai
beau faire sans squat par jour je
n'aurais pas j'en ai rien à faire ça
marche pas mais comme ces six mettons
j'avais 14 ans piquet je regarde est mon
instagram tout le temps puis que je vois
tout le temps juste du as mais comme
tels que sa veine rennes je n'entends
pas je serai comme christophe on n'est
pas une belle femme parce que j'ai pas
de cul ce que dans la société
aujourd'hui mon bus comme un baudet
courbis est correct c'est parce que oui
c'est beau les courbes mais comme tu
penses qu'à man il faut s'arrêter
puisque d'argenlieu c'est pas juste le
faire même si parce que c'est drôle
comment si ça change parce que mettons
on retombe en 2001 était réussi
[Rires]
tandis que ça termine non quand elle est
également en baisse pas comme si nous
étions cultivait vraiment seul et y est
on est on faisait partie de cette
génération là moi comme s'il nous ôtons
activement était là avec les risques
qu'elle colle faisons le faisant du lot
quand même mal d'avoir maintenant avec
mon regard de 2020 me sens mal les ados
qu'on était en parler j'aime être qu on
a parlé juste des films c'était comme
notre préoccupation c'est sûr c'est que
le médecin chose à laquelle on passe il
m'avait déposé 15 98 compte que parler
son talent et puis aujourd'hui de se
marrer maintenant leur offrait un vox
pop là là guy nantel la rue était plus
fesses ou dates en europe ils vont tout
à fait au moins 84 points un mini
macbook c'est vrai pas le mal est fait
les faits nicki minaj
il fait quelques attaches et nicki minaj
ouais c'est ça c'est les premiers comme
premières influences on à fond et exacte
après paris hilton qui tire ici c'est
tellement bon ah ouais demande pourquoi
est-ce que c'est sa musique
non j'espère que les noms les plus
chauds non mais tu le lait mais pourquoi
qu'est ce que tu as suivi tout pourrait
aller mais j'avais même pas son parfum
jamais rien fait de mal mais je les
mettais que je l'écoutais commun comme
en tous genres dans le temps je m'écoute
pas c'est la première personne peu plus
la dépouille ne savais pas mais pour la
pâte afin qu'y puis-je c'est quand même
épique que ces épées closer il y en a
pour qui c'est c'est plus triste ce soir
là mais que josé théodore
or josé théodore qui devait le gardien
et joueur le plus important de l'année
qui s'est fait pogner a trompé sa femme
avec perez hilton dans un bar lesbien
genre des photos de lui qui tient pas
résultant par la main qui l'amène dans
une chambre d'hôtel certaines
personnalités québécoises et ben il
sortait je pensais qu il sortait pas
avec la ville de lasalle à quelqu'un à
ce point là c'est moins épique
on s'en sort pas mais ça c'est donc ce
que tu as dit tantôt le sait quel
pourcentage pensée de personnes qui
soient vont vivre vont commettre pas eu
le temps au soin le le de notre
génération à vivre mais mettons de la
génération matin le mettons en avant
ce boss 75%
c'est une bonne question mais elle s y
pense vraiment beaucoup là c'est moi y
est tellement bons qu'ils m'ont écrit
après cette double pour madden et genre
j'ai vécu ceux où j'ai les faits puis
georges me sentais tellement mal putté
jeu merci d comme d'en parler puis de
nous dire comment tu te sens tu es il ya
tellement monde c'est fois qu'elle
procure est pas seul
est-ce que celle tonnes de revoir de
revoir le couple s'était rendu à avoir
un pourcentage de 75% qui vont à
l'encontre de la vision traditionnelle
du groupe situe le temps de le revoir
mais moi j'aurais jamais pensé faire
c'est tirer de vraiment être au top tout
comme ça va devenir d'un même jeu très
honnêtement je me serais chier tu
mettrais chez touchera m étonne que je
me serais rechi tuteuré georges terrey
vraiment potes
la couche jeudi je m'étais je suis
vraiment une fille qui prend le coupe
classique ne suis pas une fille qui
promet qu au pouvoir sur ces plateformes
comme ça que ce soit ait fait je suis
mitigé parce que parce que c'est ça fait
pas partie mais pour moi le fait de
verser
deux personnes peu importe quel sexe qui
s'aiment picchi ils veulent partager
justement tous ensemble et dans
l'intimité
parce que c'est arrivé une fois que non
non non tu crois que c'est possible et
c'est peut-être là septembre quelque
chose je pauvre je sais pas mais non non
non vraiment un peu c'est moi je suis
avec mon copain ça allait juste pas très
bien que tu puisses à excusant raymond
ges le mais je pense pas que j'en ferais
jamais seule fac mais je pense qu'il ya
un bon questionnement avoir par rapport
à ça parce qu'il ya tellement de plus en
plus de couples ouvert des coupes qui
que ça ne dérange plus typiques et
justement il se destine mois le nombre
de personnes à qui j'ai parlé qui me
disent moi je crois pas qu'on peut aimer
une personne en est vite
c'est fou paraît été les mentalités au
niveau du code change tellement mais
vraiment ses fils et c'est phénoménal
donc enfin la statistique dans cette
pièce la main sur un 2 sur deux
trottoirs sur tronic a été déjà trompé
ou été trompés non attendez moi j'avais
déjà vécu à key west
ça s'est fini de même mais meiway fait
que c'est pas quelque chose qui tient je
te sens pas d'école ce sujet tellement
j'ai tellement de fierté que ça a été
vraiment offre sur mon écot at on aussi
mon orgueil comme je sais le pauvre vécu
j'ai mangé toute ma vie avec la cuillère
d'argent ne livrant pas vécu des chèques
juin
puis ça ce n'était rien comme ça mais je
comprends qu est ce qui a amené il a
fallu comme que je me bats que je me
reconstruise
je sais que je remette en perspective
mais je mets mon ego c'est un travail
encore aujourd'hui leurs hôtes au niveau
de lego j'essaie vraiment de laisser de
côté mon ego vraiment beaucoup on le
chalet avec ma blonde talent et puis un
ami à québec on est allé voir des
chamans les guettait il était dans
l'ashram de au chaud dans le fond il ya
un documentaire sur les fixes et le wild
droit quand il se fait que c'était un
choix marquant de ce genre une
communauté autour d'un de chaman acquis
le charmant s'appelait au chaud on
écoutera ce documentaire lounge sur
netflix a aucun sens c'est de penser que
ces personnes là étaient présentes à ces
événements le ceja c'est ma faute d'en
face qui s'est passé c'est que d'autres
étaient et son talent aux états unis en
banlieue d'une petite ville vraiment
redneck puis y ont construit une ville
étaient calmes 6000 habitants à vivre le
team est lâché son petit chien et lui ce
qui prônait c'est vraiment comme le
fruit love puis de la mort de lego fake
tout rien qui dérange puis tout le monde
et free spirit elle sauf qu'il y avait
aussi une assistante qui elle comme une
espèce de pas aux tripes fait que les
communes de la guerre avec avec la ville
y ont mis ils ont mis la salmonelle dans
l'ohio ici d'empoisonner la ville à côté
et voit s'entraîner avec des gones s'est
dit joe biden in arms et 1.6 et comme si
ces incroyables se dit que mental est
que ce soir et vous aux états unis puis
on a on a pas moins parler parce que
toutes les fois qu'on entend parler de
sexe ça a fini à
asus est de damas tout ça est fini il ya
le il ya plus de morts dans cette
histoire mais c'est quand même
complètement un show qui a vu que ça ça
tournait vraiment mal le fait avec ce
n'est pas pour ça que celui-ci min puis
luire pertinents ok merde que ces deux
gars là et elle était là et quand ça
s'est passé c'est là qu'ils se sont
rencontrés puis on est allé s'asseoir
avec eux puis on est parti son être est
pleine
en fait ils ont fait boire de l'hydromel
puis j'avais déjà vu l'hydromel avant
dans ma vie mais jamais comme seul ça
m'a vraiment fait partir le dans un
autre dans un autre triple c'était
vraiment will puis lui c'est ce qui est
enseigné ce qu'ils disaient comme ton
ego si ce qui tire vers l'arrière oui
vraiment c'était il ya rien à perdre
personne s'ils tombent si t'as pas d'ego
personnes potter tm est blessé ou quoi
que ce soit à personne va te fare tir de
pernes suis incapable de comprendre mais
ton at me tromper
pourquoi oui puis mon ego et pau orthez
mais je fais juste comprendre que ce qui
fonctionne pas pu la relation peut-être
qu'à fonctionner pas petit quelque chose
qui est à l'époque dès qu'on pourra
jamais revenir dessus mais cet opus un
peu le travail que je suis au quotidien
maintenant décider si tôt bah oui ça
m'est émettons mois pour la branche
véhicules
si je dirais le fait que je suis allé
voir ailleurs ça enlève tellement rien à
mon nom c'est ce genre 0 que ça enlève
rien à l'amour que j'ai pour lui tu es
fax pour sap était lui-même y vécut un
peu la même chose que toi tu es puis
surtout que j'avais fait une vidéo était
comme un gosse et gilles a donc affiché
comme alors c'est moi qui alors d'une
comme c'est moi qui ai fait des codes
pas correct dans ma tête c'était
vraiment sauté je me disais hé bien il
ya vraiment le droit de le filet puis de
le ressentir comme il veut lutter par
rapport à la vidéo mais je me disais
c'est moi qui ai la dune comme c'est
serré en patois st paul le boss que je
voulais le faire oui c'est ça mais ça
fait mal tout ça je peux commencer
comment tu peux te sentir médecins comme
c'était comme si c'est toi qui avait
fait lui aussi quelque chose quand ça
t'arrive ça t'arrive même sir de compter
autant contrôler c'est seulement si pour
toi qui était la cause de
le sommet s'est probablement
irrationnelle le communes comme parle
mais moi j'ai moi je les fait vivre
aussi bien ce puits cc c'est vraiment le
pire sentiment après mais après la moi
ça fait comme celle là je commence à
arrêter mon gloire mais comme j'ai
tellement fait une introspection que
j'avais jamais fait sur moi monté tout
pour seulement une question est pourquoi
genre pourquoi j'ai fait deux sets puis
comme mettons 6 a vraiment bien été pour
une ombre maintenant ça a vraiment bien
été le plus souvent sa vraie pas mal
moins le métier pour une heure
oui mais c'est que tu te dis à quel
point je suis égoïste d'avoir pensé à un
mois seulement et seulement montrer à
mes désirs à des pulsions et aux fonds
qui comme je peux moi j'aurais jamais
pensé faire ça après l'avoir fait dit
jean chrétien qui a fait qu'une personne
puis comme comment j'ai pu autant
l'oublier à ce moment c'est pas que ce
tu sais pas c'est plus que le moment
présent il sa cache autre chose puis moi
je suis vraiment mal géré la suède est
arrivé tôt dans une relation qui a duré
cinq ans
puis ça a été difficile passée par
dessus mais on est on est passé
par-dessus purement dans les salles a
terminé mais c'était pas en lien avec
sauf que j'ai jamais été capable de
trouver le pourquoi de cette arrivée
inquiet même encore aujourd'hui mais
encore aujourd'hui
audric maintenant aujourd'hui la
relation est terminée et fuck
ce serait impertinent fait que je trouve
la réponse à cette question certainement
pertinents mais mais c'est ça j'imagine
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui était
pas communiquer ou quitter pau qui avait
un besoin c'est peut-être des fossés de
l'auto sabotage carrément déficit mais
jamais puis ça a été vraiment difficile
après sud reconstruire une confiance
monde ici le tpiy si la personne a
coiffé de la partie avait confiance en
toi mais toi aussi quand finaux faire de
même les stones estime de twain jeanne
d'arc saucisse est vraiment difficile à
reconstruire train de redevenir une
personne que quelques thèmes que tu as
pris six ans qui toi même tu as
confiance et m'a bien dit c'est
exactement
ben oui c'est sur tf1 personnes à
pointer du doigt pierre adjugé source
quand il fait mal aux autres tu blesses
les autres blessé au tendon fait que fax
et se dit je pense que mettons ce qu'est
ce que genre ce que j'apprendrai de
tulle c'est que je pense que ça ça
arrive qu'ils affaires qui sont
accumulées qui sont pas extérieur et
maintenant libération je pense souvent
mais tant pis c'est tellement important
du genre église à faire dit que ça
horrible la communication la chose la
plus importante pour kkb tonton
vernouillet plein
oui clairement portes verrouillées plein
une petite boutade aborde ces fêtes de
bordes à quoi que ce soit il me semble
que le terme pour se le rappelle plus
les caisses vides tout le temps au fur
et à mesure après c'est pas rêver
n'importe quoi puis-je or c'est vrai
crissement mieux gérer toutes les
situations
mais le problème c'est que des fois
mettons pas la communication des fois tu
peux te cacher tu peux refuser la
communication parce que tu sais que la
communication va amener à la fin la
relation intime et ont une communication
consciente le défunt s'y mettant le jeu
je veux vraiment pas parler pour toi
l'analyse qu'en france si je suis dans
le champ du le mois mais la
communication concerne de s'asseoir de
feuilles en ce moment ça va pas bien
moi je veux faire mais ma carrière sur
les médias sociaux
thaïs eu ou peu importe le registre
c'est quoi votre situation
mais d'avoir cette conversation là
peut-être que ça égal à terminer la
relation puis ça c'est tough d'accepter
ce site offre de dia qui non on va avoir
cette conversation là où est ce qu'on va
tous les deux se rendent compte que ça
fonctionne fait qu'un place on va se
garder la tête dans le sable jusqu'à
temps que quelque chose arrive là c'est
clair à ce qu on arrête parce que là
j'ai une vraie raison oui de ces
journées une vraie raison de séparer
dans un éclat dans un quoi que ce soit
c'est parce que parce que souvent c'est
ce qui arrive avec les conversations
très consciente le deux fois au québec
moi quand toi tu fais ça si on a parlé
avec antoine biton le camp tout fait ça
ça me fait me sentir comme ce oui mais
peut-être que la personne n'est pas
prête à changer cette action le pas ce
que parce que si les foxes rex veut
protéger la personne parce que te dis
téléphone je sais pas tout verte et je
pense qu'elle est bonne à dire mais des
fois on dirait que tu dois savoir d'où
provient ainsi jusqu'à me protéger la
personne parce que tu es on s'entend
dans un couple c'est moi ça fait cinq
ans que je suis en coupe puis je pense
que c'est normal de trouver d'autres
personnes beaupuy d'abord des felynes
pour d'autres personnes puis je suis à
100% quand cinq ans mon ex a déjà eu un
fils et nous un petit quelque chose et
comme j'ai pas il rencontre une fille
aubrée com
témoin georges à secteur en coupe mais
comme être célibataire je comprends pas
ce film fait quelque chose c'est normal
abordé en france d'avoir des connexions
avec d'autres moins mais c est ce que la
foi est une connexion plus grand avec
quelqu'un est ce que ce serait bien d'en
parler comme et chalobah tj j'ai vu marc
mollet gauche ça existe mais non mais
c'est ça mettait d'abord la conversation
après trois ans avec quelqu'un qui est
déjà j'ai le goût d'aller voir ailleurs
il était de finale qui est acquis on va
être encore plus voir ou à quitter ces
corrections
si tu veux et en anikop qu'axée mais
encore une fois c'est le genre de
conversation qui peut amener de se
réconcilier
des fois ils sont plus des bus mais dit
elle avoue paul ouest et des fois il ya
des gens qui sont pas tous six points
bons films et tire en plus défaut de
votre plus jeune tu dis pas pour la vie
fax regarde mais genre dans ma langue ça
fait cinq ans que je pensais au début
c'est peut-être mais tc caen métier moi
maintenant j'ai jamais été comme
célibataire comme je vous dis fine -
c'est maintenant ma dernière année je me
surprenais était des fois à dire des
commentaires des discordes comme
strasbourg puis comme elle et collab la
bo yibo jamais rien schiste de la beauté
mais ses juges a des tripes
si j'avais jamais embrassé un code pour
rapport dans le rapport le juge george
pompe est le gaillet quillothon
s'embrassent one à ses fans je pense que
je ne sais pas je pense que j'avais
peut-être un manque d'attention des je
sais pas joe kinder je t'avais dessus
tout ça tu mets ton que tu avais un
besoin de genre
non c'était pas exagérer que je bats
position des bras avec mon micro ça n'a
pas fonctionné
exposé par les acquis mais je peux
atteindre mon père
tandis que j'avais un check list jugeant
que je l'aimé genre à m'amener aussi une
angoisse à se dirige
mettons je m'en bats les relations piles
et ça ça veut dire qu aimer ton si on se
dit que c'est pour le long terme et même
c'est peut-être la seule personne avec
qui j'ai cinq ans puis en chantant tiens
on vieillit techniquement tu t'embarques
avec des personnes qui disent ah ben je
pense maintenant avec ses fils haute et
plus qu'on vieillit plus qu'on a envie
de stabilité plus notre invité sinon on
parlait d'enfants ont parlé de deux
projets futurs si on avait tous bords de
notre vie futur ensemble mais c'est sûr
que quand je pense comme ses poches qui
est peut-être des envies que j'ai jamais
eue mort ont coûté mon cockpit est
d'aider des tripes que j'aurais jamais
vécu pire c'est plate mais c'est
vraiment ça puis comme cg jamais été
seul j'ai jamais appris à vivre seul qui
sait ce qu'est vraiment une lacune aussi
dans mon couple était deux je pense que
je prends beaucoup les gens pour acquis
et outils je prends je prends le fait
qu'ils vont être là pour moi ci mettant
quelque chose que je comprends pas ou
que je pas capable de faire mais qu'au
fond je serai capable de le faire moi je
veux pas à prendre je comprends quitte
la personne va être là pour moitié mais
c'est vraiment moche ça m'a coûté mon
coup mais oui peut-être
je ne sais pas si un moment où est-ce
que met-on se disloquer mettons faut que
j'aille véhicu fakelaki ego en sort en
ce pont du monde on vit à 100 milles à
l'heure j'ai passé un moment tu dis bon
j'ai fait le tour
ou bien c'est un truc en plus quand je
commence dans ce que j'ai l'impression
que tu veux tout le temps ce qui te paul
oui c'est vrai c'est maintenant le temps
d'un coupe-faim semble que je serai bon
ces deux bateaux c'est juste de se
mettre en couple en moi que ma gang des
faits on est nouvellement tout
célibataire mais vraiment les gens on
respecte car le jour tout le monde en
même temps c'est le fun en même temps
parce que l'on a fait du bien ne pas se
sentir seul dans sa situation
mais comme ils ne trouvent gazon n'est
trop beau pour les comme on regarde les
go on est rentré et je trouves tu
trouves un peu pathétique genre parce
qu'on est toutes nouvelles moi c'est le
batteur
on comprend pas pour les pas tant les
attentes et c'est comme moi je dis ça
j'ai détruit de très près mais au final
je suis fixé en ce moment les genres de
films au monde
j'avais fait dans ma vie jackman est un
célibataire jusqu'à céder trip à quel
point j'ai envie de vie je ne sais pas
non c'est bon je suis là est le même
comme tout était cinq ans un couple
estime que c'est moi ça fait longtemps
que ça lui à terme et c'est après ça
c'est jean rouyer à jamais inscrits sur
tender plus que c'est plate mais non
c'est vrai elle m'a tellement sexy je
trouve de soi et du monde juste pour
leur physique beauté c'est tellement
essentiel que m
ainsi qu'avec plusieurs combattants je
n'ai pas eu beaucoup loin dans ma vie
mais j'en ai eu pis je suis je sais que
le lendemain je sais que le matin quand
je me réveille tout seul dans mon lit
pis que la veille mais ton je suis pas
dans un bon rythme et je suis mille fois
mieux j'étais mille fois mieux que quand
je me réveillais après m'avoir après
m'être saouler avec une fille qui le je
t'aime comme tu es un peu mais comme ça
de vue que le ça va être comme en mai
salut agassi s'est fait que sa devise
c'est sa vieille ville sont aussi
d'acheter un couple si je t'ai by plus
j'étais toujours en mode est ce que je
tentais parler par exemple de temps mais
je suis visé un camp c'est quoi la
la chasse-galerie le jeu fils paul je
parlais souffle mettez des frites et des
fois quand est en couple été exaucé
batteur je vivais genre mais à travers
le genre mon ami c'était comme le
téléfilm a écrit il aux matériaux à la
rejoindre
je te dis que tu es pas les gens vont le
jeter vais me coucher qu'elle a 12 de
style gothique mais le jeu comprend
tellement ces gens des foules et non 20
minutes couchés rosa genre la fierté on
tâte et le placent plutôt s'est fracturé
jusqu'à 3h bon avec les autres pour
peut-être genre l'idée de me coucher que
d'être en forme de main est vraiment
plus alléchantes
certaines cgd match vient le moment mais
si la personne est comme on va prendre
un verre puis à chaque fois ci comme ben
non mais andrew tellement pop en aval
c'est sûr c'est tellement bizarre ça
j'ai jamais vécu encore métier mettons
vraiment parler avec quelqu'un sur des
plateformes qui était jamais rencontré
et c'est trop savoir comment que
s'exprimait le maillet tout rôle futur
et puis peut-être plus une tête qui pue
la bouche mais comme havrais cette cité
envahie rencontré dans un bar comme si
de rien n'était comme un salut monter
car c'est un peu oui oui c'est bien sûr
ça fait besoin exa sénat jeudi savait
qu'on était célibataire ça fait depuis
le mois de juin passé
ouais comme touati et le maillet nestea
deux périodes de genre ou what the fuck
tout seul oui parce que définie comme
étant deux c'est tout le temps
nous te donne au projet petit construite
crois aussi été juste le fait mettons
d'abord peut-être surtout pas de compte
à rendre à personne intime et on
m'envoie au bord à trois ans jusqu'à 4
heures du matin je m'en vais chez une
amie après j'ai pas testé personnes pour
joseph d'anvers entraînant un écartement
teintées on voit qu'il ya tellement
notamment les petites et à spéciale je
trouvais tout ça moi pipi mais c'est le
fait de ne pas avoir quelqu'un avec qui
communiquer toutes ces quatre en coupe
comme tes tentes raconte que ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui et j'ai fait à
la fois puis c'est maintenant toutes des
petites victoires tout et départager
quelqu'un c'est qu'on me laisse quand
même temps aussi quand ça va moins bien
kate est offert par les départs avec
partage puis sa partie oui les qataris
seul de réapprendre si c'était vraiment
très apprendre à être bien de subir ce
temps l'eau de réapprentissage est
tellement important beaucoup de succès
je pars avec maman au téléphone hier à
[ __ ] et jetés comme je disais que
j'étais encore dont j'étais encore dans
un an
pete est jetée comme si honnêtement ce
moment j'habite tout seul jusqu'à me
tombe que ça me tente pas de sortir
pendant une semaine puis je fais
absolument rien chez moi personne très
au courant non c'est tellement besoin
juste fait ligne sur cet épisode spécial
amoureux consommer mais c'est l'autre
jour c'était vraiment malade je me dis
imagine si j'ai encore à me kiejman dans
mon lit mes exemples j'écoute patrice
mon téléphone puis jean il m'arrive de
quoi oui je m'en sors dehors des schémas
puisque rien de moins qu'il ya plus ou
non mais pour tous les siens le batteur
sont à risque de moselle bat un peu mûri
mais bath mais sinon si tu fais pas ce
temps là dessus c'est ce qu'on appelle
un bon vieux liban le titre en battant
quelque chose parce que tu aimais le fil
et en coupe il s'en crée un vide puis là
on comble cd de l'homme et je sais pas
si je sais qu'en ce moment ce que je vis
je trouve ça difficile mais je sais
qu'il faut que le ce sens je vais pas me
lancer dans les bras de quelqu'un
d'autre
puis juste mais c'est faux nous tête en
amour cette fenêtre avec quelqu'un et s
efforce de feeling est bon c'est pas mal
je sais que j'ai beaucoup d'affaires à
apprendre de tout ce qui est juif
ce succès sex education non maîtrise non
l'écouté yes c'est une bonne série
bref c'est vraiment bon ce n'est série
bleach le genre de jeu peu ce qu'on
appelle un sitcom et ses genres comédie
genre high school genre mais c'est
vraiment cool parce que c'est vraiment
trop ces situations on s'est dit des dix
personnes qui ont jamais été vraiment
représentée à l'écran le petit acquis
toutes sortes de type de relation tout
type de personnes soit des types de
corps de sexualité de toutes ces genres
tout est dit et on envoie des teutons la
série commence épisode 1 saison 1 avec
deux personnages qui baise avec une
fille qu des teutons mais incroyable de
beauté puis en tout cas il ya un épisode
où est ce qu'il ya un personnage qui
vient de plusieurs guipy ce qui est cool
de voir aussi c'est qu'ils mettront ils
sont un personnage pour qui si j'avais
vraiment grosse trop gomme et ont sauté
sur l'accord puis le fait d'être gibbs
sera pas et piano pour qui sait comme
genre c'est normal qu'en dise le cpie
dans la vie c'est cela oui il ya des
cadres et zae ils disent leurs paroles
c'est ok aux fans pigeons pour d'autres
pour un puits pour d'autres ces genres
s'ils gardent cependant puis ça pourrit
n'est d'ailleurs pige en russie jamais
lassé de vie moyenne en france soit plus
pas dû passer ma vie avec moi après
mickey ce que j'ai entamé ce peuple à
des fins personnelles ou iie comme fils
d'immigrés anti genre je pense afrique
pour l'afrique un autre petit ses
parents c'est comme le lac simon la
parle pas trop il le lui arrêté d'aller
elle se croyait plus arrêter la règle à
l'église parce que ben parce qu'ils
sentaient paul bienvenue le think est
donnée de retourner le prête il prend le
lui c'est un moment où chamakh était
moins bien dans sa peau blime prête une
trempe easy to love someone du first
have to love yourself pige à six fois
plus cher dans l'armée c'est vrai c'est
beau j'ai plus non j'ai peu pleuré mais
c'est tellement beau que c'est tellement
vrai tellement conditions selon soir
elle est dans une génération parce que
ce tic en ce moment c'est comme on est
tellement lancement à l'acceptation mais
de toute la saison pour faut vraiment
être piratés on a des lacunes dans notre
génération mais seuls crise qu'il faut
être fier de moi c'est vrai jcc de pour
rebondir ce que tu veux dire de s'aimer
soi même c'est vraiment important de
tout le temps se poser cette question là
hier chalet puis j'allais faire du
l'escaladent avec droit et les chalets
grimpé de 10 me mettez lui est vraiment
vraiment super spirituel demandait de
tout le temps se poser la question est
ce que en ce moment tu fais ce que tu
veux fond - est-ce qu'en ce moment
vraiment tu fais ce que tu veux faire
parce que si toi tu fais pas ce que tu
veux voir si t'aime pas ta direction
dans ta vie tu pourras jamais à être
bien dans rien oui c'est vrai sur toutes
les routes les aspects de ta ville était
pas ce que je disais j'ai de la
difficulté avec le stress va faire le
cpie je tendance est négative des trucs
qu'ils détiennent
est ce que tu aimes tout ce que tu fais
de ma première réponse a été oui plat
après ce gars comme commencé à me poser
des questions plus précises 120 enfants
dix petits-enfants même pas pensé mais
jamais de métier pilar pilar on allait
bien au point
ce qui était commun qui est monté cet
aspect là
la vie est ce que tu aimes celui là pas
plus qu'il faut c'est ok puis mettons
cet aspect de mon peuple ce qu'il faut
c'est déjà deux à faire facilement que
tu peux régler mais c'est impossible
d'aimer toute sa vie jean c'est normal
c'est mathieu s'est passé mais taux
moyen d'emprunt rentrée de saint-gilles
lui probable qu'en ce moment il ya pas
mal tout de sa vie c'est comme il
travaille juste sur des trucs qui veut
faire sur que c'est pas tout le monde le
sait le succès avec on a le contrôle
c'est ça la femme à ses seuls à fortis
jozef au final au final c'est par
exemple c'est quand même il s'est acheté
un vieux vers heures avec la saq est
vite fait juste partie puis tout le
monde a le contrôle ultime étant mon
métier j'aime faire de la musique mais
mettons le moment où est ce que je
l'autre le truc de stocks on s'attaque
ce dans la même action
hu que d'aller jouer un show d'une
spatule talent en plus si je disais tu
faisais moi il n'y a pas une projet
c'est que j'aime faire la paperasse ce
qui me fait chier métier dis moi mais si
vraiment le projet tulle m la paperasse
c'est correct négatifs mais je crois
quand même qu'il faut que dans toutes
les actions taille pense à toi tu penses
à ce que tu veux vraiment fait quelque
chose qu'il y aurait rien au final qui
tente de faire là dedans peut-être que
c'est pas la bonne enfant mais avoir de
l'amour propre pour ça je trouve qui est
personnellement c'est un travail
constant et aussi des exemples ne pas
avoir besoin de personne le savoir que
tu peux compter sur toi que c'était
justement moi je pense que c'est quelque
chose que j'ai à comprendre des malfrats
une relation c'est que moi je moi pour
moi en ce moment
j'avais besoin de chez lui et comme
témoin j'ai pas besoin de toi je sers
plus qu'elle soit la moins
je suis heureux tu es dans ma vie je
suis heureux c'est hélas tant mieux mais
comme moi ce n'est pas ce témoin c'était
vraiment comme j'ai besoin de toi tu es
oui c'est ça qui comme il ya beaucoup de
c est une bonne distinction enfin bref
c'est vraiment une bonne sanction puis
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas tout le
monde qui l'a fait ouais de d'actes de
diriger ta vie pour toi tu as comme on
disait de commencer à parler aux sables
et dangereux rapidement oui c'est parce
que le rapidement le monde que tu
connais comment ça s'adressait à tous en
deuil
est ce que vous venez moi je vais ya
beaucoup de noms qui font très rares là
aussi la caq sont en coupe c'est comme
mais ça vient trop vite et qui t'es qui
oui avant tout se perd toi je regarde
c'est important de pas tomber dans une
dynamique d'interdépendance bastille
mettons-le alcoolique et dépendant à
bière si c'est pas parce qu'ils aiment
soucy apopo team et on peut vraiment
être qui trippent ses bières et mets
déguster la bière sans alcool et
mélancolie qui attire plaisir non
manufactu fake des footeux faut arrêter
quelqu'un pas parce que tu le lem parce
que tant des dépendants aux bornes où la
personne est en partie impôts j
appartiens pas exact qui gère les deux
aussi vers le haut mais les genres les
deux ont ni des personnes anciens qui
font leur chemin en parallèle celle à la
théorie des lignes parallèles
cette théorie non c'est la théorie des
lignes paraissent une théorie que
j'arrêtais pas de d'expliquer à rodez ah
oui mais l'ont jamais mis parce qu'ils
sont trop intelligents
tétreault et c7 c'était sûrement
comprendront pas mettre trop mais c'est
c'est l'objectif c'est trouver quelqu'un
qui va en ligne parallèle à la tienne
qui va être la plus proche possible de
toi
et non de juste fusionner en ligne parce
qu'on est donc tes deux personnes si pea
place de continuer vers l'avant tu fais
juste fusionner talent et 6 ans née
d'une rencontre que tu es rendu vraiment
trop loin de talent initial ça va sauter
dessus puis à linverse admettons que
deux lignes comme ça mais qui ont un
degré de différence mais en allant vers
l'avant le degré au final devient
tellement lointain et il le degré
devient énorme 60e rien fait pour donner
un coup de volant
ouais c'est exact fait de se laisser
partir le truc c'est que le bus s'est
trouvée c'est de toi avoir ton objectif
tombe personnel oui puis de trouver
assez lent s'oublier
mais oui mais oui exact c'est facile
d'oublier maintenant on met en commun à
la plupart des gens aujourd'hui que ce
soit en coupe non le même temps qu on
extrapole un petit peu la conversation
vers quelque chose d'autre que le coupé
tu leur demandes recul vu le recul de 5
en recul de 10 ans c'était quoi ton but
principal c'était quoi tu voulais faire
qu'est ce que tu voulais ce que tu
voulais laisser une marque sur quelque
chose est ce que j'aimais tant que le
disant très demandé dans dix ans qui
souffre de se poser cette question là on
réalise que les choses ont changé pas
mal
il se met tant que tu dis c'est normal
qu'il est chaud de chance non mac les
intérêts changent si tu ramènes 6 à 5 1
le 5 ans est ce que tu fais qu'est-ce
que tu pensais que tu allais forte oui
après c'est sûr traces ton parcours
studio qui est ce que ça va changer
quand ça va changer ce que ça s'est
perdu ou est-ce que ça le juste modifié
parce que j'ai eu un intérêt que j'ai
découvert d'importantes oui c'est vrai
c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai réécouté
l'autre jour vers écouter ce que
j'arrive d'une mini tournée américaine
au ce 2 5 et 11 avec avec une artiste
rare endroit qui excellent puis chez le
genre d'idée stick j'aime sur l'accent
du sud genre des états unis gens comment
on parle si je trouve ça marrant
c'est vraiment l'accent le match ou
méconnus de ce qui se passait société
qui met ses qui met genre remonté comme
un qui parle et plus on écoute et
qu'elle gagne et ce qui arrive le pis il
dit jardy s'était demandé ce qu'ils sont
et rempli savez il savait pas qu'elle
était survenue lundi 10 mai américaine à
bamako
c'est excellent chez toi danza qui te
penses tu vas tu crées personnes se voir
est tous très tendus pis dans le bassin
mais sur scène moi j'ai tellement de la
misère à me projeter dans le futur pour
poser une question qui me stresse piège
pas bien que ce matin tu vois où je
t'aime dans cinq ans je ne voyais pas ça
mais qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi tes
nouveaux petits prochain projet comme
sweet fois comme dans l'horaire manger
je sais pour l'instant non mais je sais
pas pourquoi c'est une question qui me
stresse autant jamais prochainement mais
ce qu'est ce que tu as comme un job à
poser des questions layard puis m'a dit
mettons que tu meurs demain qu'est ce
que tu aimerais que le monde qu'est ce
que tu aimerais qui restent des mois
ouais puis en réponde à cette question
là possiblement tu réponds un petit peu
un objectif plus globale de du résultat
vite et mettons maintenant que le jeu
prendre de quoi
puis je suis encore une fois personne en
particulier mais maintenant que je t'ai
a sorti de mon bac
je rentrais dans un travail au
gouvernement qui paient bien dit pis que
je faisais d'une façon tout les jours
pis que là je me pose la question tu
mets ton qu'est ce que j'aimerais c'est
que si demain je meurs qu'est ce qui
reste
faut quand même que tu trouves une
raison de ce que tu fais c'est peut-être
que dans cette double verrez une famille
sa mort est comblé tiens ça mais je
pense quand même que c'est important de
se poser la question de forme et donc
demain je disparaisse ce serait quoi
l'objectif ce serait quoi que j'aimerais
que les gens sera plus rapide puis si la
réponse c'est quelque chose que tu es
pas en train de faire peut-être ça vaut
la peine de se reposer a été de regarder
cette réponse rentable se poser des
questions sur qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de fond c'est des gens qui sont
confortables là dedans je t'aime à
d'abord une brusque pour palma que
s'accomplisse ailleurs le lancement
d'adobe non plus que tu veux laisser ta
ta trace les noms mais on çà posthuma
gaccio sa peau si on me dit qu'il a
compris mais toi ok ok vous passez moi
j'aimerais vraiment que si je meurs le
monde dise stand belle personne c'est
[Rires]
une bonne et belle personne qui est
effectif
j'ai protégé c'est de pas être la
personne qui qui manquent il joue dans
le dos qui pend dans le dos qui qui qui
passe un passé commun éthique et essayer
d'être une belle personne que je
rencontre quelqu'un puis si la personne
se fait j'en garde une bonne impression
y va de sa manie steve white 10 secondes
quelqu'un que ce soit pour une seconde
ou ou en un mois ou un an ou dix ans
chevrette prudence était très gentlemen
succès personnel
soupe à sa personne le ton et gentlemen
puis tes précieux le décliner féminin
est le seul le 10 mai mais ouais et puis
après ça se sait pour mettons
l'entourage proche
oui mais j'aurais socom aussi laissé une
trace mettons plus large puisque je
pense qu'en ce moment par le podcast une
vrai bonheur on a laissé une trace le
jeudi il ya eu beaucoup d'échos et
reçoit des mains sales oui tout respire
du monde le monde écrit des messages et
georges de me toucher 6 et ça ça
m'inspire et cela n'a ce qui va vraiment
changer pour toucher l'été des inconnus
le dha genre sur une grande échelle mais
quand même que ce qui fait sa part le
podcast par la musique d'avoir quelque
chose qui qui reste le type et le chemin
quatre fans album still phone c'est
qu'il est précieux il existe pour
toujours oui puisqu'elle conditionne un
pacte avec des gens s'en souviennent un
peu ben tu continues à plus de vivre à
travers la création mais oui d'avoir un
impact positif de le savoir très de le
sentir je pense c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important mais on est aussi sur
les rangs
ensuite c'est moi je sais que maintenant
avec ma chaîne youtube c'est tout chaque
de cash possible rester vidéo que c'est
sûr que qu'il faut partir manger un
gâteau que chez extrêmement fier c'est
le culte est plus fort et ma vidéo être
vulnérable à coeur ouvert
je suis vraiment fier que je me sens
aussi justement avec d'autres
personnalités du web pour montrer que le
puck oui j'aimerais ça faire des vidéos
plus dans ce style de jeu tellement tu
montres etc et comme on est tout normal
qu'on vit tout justement des drm donc on
a tout vécu des étapes de vie qu'on a
tous des complexes et tout témoin c'est
pour moi c'est vraiment important de
montrer que les personnes qui c'est
parce que peut-être que pour la vie de
rejoindre en ce moment tu sais moi je
suis son idole on ne sait pas trop
peut-être
tesson mal de quelqu'un bon peut-être
m'est témoin je veux que la personne qui
idolâtrent ça se distingue les youtuber
ou les personnes sur le web justement se
rendent compte qu on est toutes des gens
vrais ou financier on vit tout des
mauvaises journées des fois qu'on se
lève qu'on se trouve lettres et des fois
qu'on se lève qu'on est
conte et crissements pas qui était puis
on vit tout des étapes de visiter
mettons r&d fois ton taxi veut pas
prendre la carte à carte car c'est ici
oui mais je trouve qu'elle est je pense
que c'est seul un pas que j'aimerais
avoir vraiment de montrer qu'elle est ce
qu'on est vrai pour les tout comme ne
pas dire normal parce que je trouve sain
c'est pas le bon mot mais bah c'est tout
le monde vit la même chose - feu
vraiment même puis je pense c'est une
réflexion j'ai continué à me poser parce
qu'on parlait avec thomas levet a
comparé de pornographie quand la
représentation de la sexualité dans
lequel dans la pornographie en fait la
lpc à des millénaires de la sexualité en
tant que tel je pense qu'ils pouvaient
plus largement que juste pour la
sexualité la représentation consulaire
de plein de choses parce qu'ils nous
aient montré ce qui nous est projeté que
ce soit un film que ce soit justement
sur instagram les trucs les ché je
trouve c'est vraiment important car 1
contre bâle en de gens justement comme
toi qui qui montre que c'est tout le
monde vit les mêmes choses au final je
pense est sûre ça reste exigeant
oui je retiens kiki qui écoute les
vidéos vont se reconnaître va se
reconnaître beaucoup plus que quelqu'un
qui écoute je suis professeur mark
wallinger qui montre une ville trop
polis pire serait que les gens se
souviennent de moi comme une personne
qui se prend pas au sérieux qui était
drôle qu'avait dit ce fan qui a vécu en
tabarnak ses bons mots probablement que
j'aimerais ça j'avais répondu à un gars
dans une entrevue pour le soleil qui
m'avait demandé qu'est ce que tu veux
que le monde se souvient de ces tests la
conversation avec aimé le roi qu'on
avait parlé de la la fine ligne entre
une utopie une dystopie dans dans
lesquels on existe en ce moment le dif
et qu'on est autant proche d'avoir une
pandémie mondiale qui vous a été annulé
tout le monde puis
des critiques et matic qui vont mettre
fin à l'humanité qu'on la connaît puis
en même temps on est avec la technologie
et tous tellement proches de capable de
faire un monde et coresponsable de tout
moment tout le monde est accepté tout le
monde s'accepte comme ils sont tout le
monde accepte les autres commissions
tout le monde se respecte et qu'on est
vraiment à mi chemin on marche sur un
câble les tifs vraiment mince entre les
deux à fond si l'image qu'il avait
répondu c j'aimerais ça faire partie du
poids qui fait tomber vers l'utopie du
fait que j'aimerais sortie vous apparaît
par ajustement les actions vegan qui
boivent le sait avant de rencontrer
jessie j avais aucune idée en moins des
trucs le terreau 0 j'avais aucune des
mois je n'avais aucune idée de l'impact
de la viande sur nos os
je n'avais aucune idée je me considérais
comme voir un jour l'enlever l'ofce
attention mais j'avais jamais entendu
parler de ça depuis que je m'y intéresse
je réalise vraiment que c'est important
oui comme spi puis à travers ce à
travers des discussions nuancer avec
plein de monde différent à travers toute
la création je demande du studio du fait
qu'il ya plein de conversation qui sont
ici pleinement qui donnent leur opinion
je trouve que j'ai envie de continuer à
travailler vers le pouvoir lutte pour
les proches de jeu français serait
dommage de tomber au bon oui mais sûre
c'est vraiment impressionnant justement
des gens compétents les vegas où tu es
quelqu'un qui est qu'il faut lgbt plus
qui prend sa source et plateforme
vraiment intensément genre c'est
peut-être à cause de toi il ya
maintenant j'ai pas 150 personnes qui
sont devenues vegas et au delà leur
soient des lignes on reçoit des messages
souvent de ce week end plus que 101
quand je pense au budget si c'est
l'impact montée juste heure pour la
planète et où l'impact que ça le cct
vraiment ça fait que non mais c'est une
bonne question à se poser et on invite
aussi deux autres stars à se poser ces
questions là je pense qu'il doit déjà
partout qui s'imposent et une coupe des
cas c'est ça se pourrait qu est ce que
ça va bien pour toi ta couche travaille
sur un gros projet je n'ai pas encore si
c'est le réaliser un gros projet oui par
rapport justement à l'impact des réseaux
sociaux et puis plus pour éduquer les
jeunes aussi par rapport à ça parce que
tous les jeunes ils veulent tomber tout
avec des influenceurs message savent pas
nécessairement c'est quoi c'est quoi
étonner influence aurait tout puis
j'aimerais c'est justement m'associer
avec d'autres personnes qui font
exactement la même chose pour qu'on
puisse montrer comme nos vrais visages
on sait quoi la réalité de tout c'est
cool c'est cher l'acquisition de
non c'est avec les éditions prête mais
comme toi parce que praticien un coup
très dur coup oui enfin cache la tulle
mais c'est un projet qui me stresse un
peu c'est quand certain que mon envie je
trouve pas une autre issement jamais
écrit pour quoi que ce soit factice
c'est sûr que c'est un vraiment un défi
mais moi je vais le relever à 100%
déficit et je voulais pas avoir
quelqu'un qui écrit pour moi de
commencer l'écriture
oui j'ai commencé vraiment pas vite je
vous dise comment ça se passe et c'est
spécial spécial vraiment mais je suis
rencontre puisse choquer c'est vraiment
le bon moment dans ma vie en ce moment
parce que je t'ai menti je me retrouve
certes et j'ai tellement de temps pis
j'ai envie j'ai envie d'un projet
différent qu'à youtube en ce moment
parce que c'est le fonio totti georges
je pense une vidéo par semaine j'aime
vraiment ça ça me passionne
mais d'abord un projet d'une envergure
que j'aurais jamais pensé pour vivre
dans ma vie puis surtout qu'une maison
d'édition me fasse confiance
c'est à ce moment qu'est couru après le
projet chaud c'est d'autant plus beau
c'est hot
ça va t'amener à tous passé une allée
plus loin puis à pousser la réflexion
plus loin ce que tu aimes vraiment
vraiment et je pense que c'est ce que
j'ai besoin en ce moment
puis je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui ont besoin d'être c'est aussi
en ce moment je n'ai pas jeunes enfants
ben oui charles de sujets un peu ça sent
vraiment le style mais c'est une opinion
sur mettons les comptes ni fabien on va
probable je suis tellement mitigés mais
ce qui me rend malade est ce aussi je
pense qu'il est beau chalet sujet sans
trancher avec sujet fait le chien
on parlait tous les jeunes comme ça fait
un peu partie de ces que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
d'influenceurs créateurs de contenu pour
important qu'on les appelle qui réalise
pas l'impact et la responsabilité qui en
par rapport à leur mode histoire et moi
je crois pas que tu en as communauté
c'est pas ta responsabilité
moi je crois que c'est un responsable
c'est parce qu'il en a hérité si je
voudrais même si tu t'es créer une
communauté tôt malgré tout une
responsabilité une formule 100%
moi je moi je trouve et qui je trouve
que met-on moi femme de 25 ans qui vient
dans mon corps j'ai utilisé mon sujet
des faux seins me tombent d'entrée j'ai
déjà eu des chirurgies plastiques
georges comprend que peut avoir envie de
modifier quelques parties de son corps
et où si je vois exemple lisant start 1
ont ni fan moi dans ma vie rencontre
contre le foot et ça me change rien mais
si je me mets dans la peau d'une jeune
une jeune adolescente qui commence et
secondaire qui va pas tant bien en ce
moment qui piquait qui suit l'exemple
qu'il aime vraiment beaucoup qui voit se
voir à quel point que c'est tellement
facile c'est tellement simple qui en ce
moment tels que moi j'ai pas d'argent je
sais pas comme comment subvenir à mes
besoins je suis je répète du latin pain
c'est là que ça me cause un plaisir et
ça me rend vraiment tout seul comme
devant l'aspect des chirurgies
plastiques ou justement ce aussi simple
et aussi facile parce que la réalité
s'expose pas vrai que tout le monde qui
vont se créer un iphone devront faire
sans des pièces jaunes fucking poterie
puis je sais pas ce qui m'attend mois
par rapport aux nous dit tout et je
comprends qu'il faut s'aimer mais je
pense pas que c'est une bonne idée de
faire comme si steria était l'envoyé des
nous dit parce que je pense que veut pas
disons dans son état est pas rendu
compte mais dans les tons historique à
l'oeuf et 6h à 10h
le nombre de nouveaux cas l'envoi y
était déjà surprise que salah et pop et
non d'argent qu'elle investit justement
dans ces chirurgies plutôt pourquoi pas
est rentable
j'habite ici ils m'ont traité parce
qu'elle est fière de son corps pis c'est
une chose qui se shootent à petit je
laisse une chose d'arrêter d'être bien
d'être confortable mais c'est quoi le
message qu'elle sans volonté oui j'aime
c'est surtout son auditoire est
constitué à 80%
je note de la chambre est vraiment
qu'ils trouvent quel impact est pas
nécessairement post dans vos idées nous
parce que tu as envie de le faire c'est
une chose mais le team le cctld
monétiser sa sexualité sans corps ouais
c c'est grâce à ce qu'un sa sortie
rejeté en californie puis on s'excite et
le moment parce que à force de
transgresser l'aller la ligne devient
vraiment flou en 1 million da fort le
fait que celle ci c'est l'exemple que je
t'ai donné les gens au s1 garde même par
mois c'est cool tu veux t'en faire sans
voici comment oui pilote tu tombes dans
quelque chose d'autre puis tu pauvres
est que toutes ces affaires là sont bien
encadrés ce pauvre est que quelque chose
d'autre en tant que tel et et bienfaits
l'était il ya un bureau ici le qui font
font la pointe dans le studio le spo
vrai que c'est tout et il vous dira la
ligne plus tu transgresse la ligne plus
tu l'as renfloue plus est difficile pour
quiconque de hamla j'accepte mon corps
qui fait une offre
gaia index venir te voir tu va durer est
ce que vraiment pour être bien avec moi
même je suis obligé de com mais des
photos sexy sur instagram qui serait
plus à l'aise qu'elle avait juste mis
des photos d'elle tout nu sur internet
gratuit on dirait que c'est le fait
qu'ils aient de l'argent on dirait que
adressé ce qui je trouve qu'elle est
l'expérience est intéressante
moi je moi quand j'ai vu ça je me suis
dit aïe crise andré j'aurais envie de
faire à semblant de mass-start et en
iphone pied comme témoin tout et moi
j'ai vu l'histoire exemple i want je le
fais mais comme mettre des photos
quel spot sp des vraies photos de moi
tout numéro puis l'argent que je fais
avec seul le donner à une cause c'est
oui si ça m'était après ça y avait des
gens avec qui j'en ai parlé comme si une
bonne des piments
c'est les gens seraient peut être fâché
de ses patrons de payer pour cette cause
là même s'il ya un lien qui est fait sur
le fait que les fans de str à lille ok
c'était comme envoyer moi un don
n'importe quel montant vous envoyez nous
des gens à la ramasse et comme 500 mille
pièces pour les forêts en australie
tisser comme genre bravo aux genres et
styles d'arts goudiaby
c'est sûr que je mets mais on dit que vu
que de l'argent de poche à bien deux
livres t'as pas besoin d'être sauter on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir un iphone pour
payer nos trucs l'envi tamic comme tu
disais la cote qui ont lifan se prend
aussi cette question là aussi la pause
il s'est quand même qu'il ya un site web
qui vont prendre une cote sur des photos
de toi nu oui si l'on pose la question
de leur coach veut dire c'est quoi c'est
maintenant que c'est comme pétillant de
l'appétit à nice prennent à chaque type
ya six prévenus ils prennent deux
piasses comprennent pas et pour ça la
fait que je pense et ça aussi en effet
fait le calcul il veut dire tabarnak
c'est beaucoup sa garde mail par année
c'est quoi ces 10000 pièces qui se
prépare moi ça va concerner par mois
c'est 1 mais par mois ils se prennent
dix mille pièces par mois sur le monde
c'est fou pitié si ce n'est ce pas ça
gâche à quai ou si nos valeurs lice pour
ce qui est aussi mais georges l'ultra la
sq que n'importe qui fait n'importe quoi
que son corps est une bulle de montrer
site chine mais on dirait que juste le
message de dire je peux faire mettons je
te mets dans la peau de johnny qui je
peux faire de l'argent mais sexuelle
c'est juste que je trouve que ça rend
tout ceux accessibles parce que tu es
après le monde ya plein de jeunes qui
avaient jamais entendu parler dans les
femmes mais elle était juste le fait
qu'ils soient au courant les deux sauté
jeu comme à thé mettons les chirurgies
plastiques montée j'ai des faux seins
mais j'ai vraiment eu de mauvaises
expériences que j'ai fait une vidéo
youtube par rapport à ceux ci j'avais
une bonne expérience j'aurais jamais
de yoto par rapport à ça je les fait
justement parce que j'étais écoeuré de
voir à quel point que c'est quand même
un peu de mode de parler puis je trouve
ça vraiment correct d'avoir des
chirurgies sait pas ce qui me ramène à
life ce qui met mal à l'aise si les je
pense que les influenceurs réalise pas
que quand qu'en ayant eu des bonnes
expériences et en partageant leurs
expériences d'un ça rend tout ce facile
et accessible pour les gens qui te
suivent t puis j'aurais été la première
maison quand j'étais jeune j'aimais pas
1005 j'aurais été la première à voir une
vidéo de n'importe qui qui s'est fait
refaire les seins qu'elle j'aime que je
suis me dire comme écrire c'est vrai en
france après tout les possibilités moi
j'aime peu j'aime pas mais simple
pourquoi je les mains d'ici peu je vais
juste me dis je vais économiser mon
argent je vais me refaire les seins mais
je trouve que le message qu'ils étaient
censés c'est pas ça c'est de dire aux
gens de s'accepter comme ils sont les
artistes de s'aimer puis d'apprendre à
aimer ton corps comme qui était factice
j'ai repris une bizarre avec tout ça
parce que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui réalisent pas à quel point ils
ont un impact dans la vie des gens
pillent comme je trouve ça plate les
gens qui disent que leur leurs abonnés
c'est pas leurs responsabilités parce
que oui c'est ta responsabilité des
abonnés thing qui on n'est pas à l'abri
l'été on fait tous des erreurs dans vie
puis on veut on veut tout non faire des
erreurs sur le sol instable les
internets n'annoncerait installera
william hague au fond plus que d'autres
mais je vous en pour centrer mais il
faut toujours garder en tête qu'ils nous
regardent
petit mode au moment où max tu arrives
et georges a pas répercuté déjà good for
earth peut pas faire ce qu'avait dit
c'est mon opinion il vraiment pour
achever la dessus puis on continue de se
poser des questions sur la cl le bien ou
le mal de cette histoire j'ai mai mais
oui mais je sens que tu allais dire que
tout est tantôt sur les seins parce que
tu mets ton se fait refaire les seins
c'est une option alternative
les gîtes non mais l'alternative de à
prendre l'apprentissage 2006 a fait je
sais pas moi même temps ça faisait 25
ans que je suis dans mon corps puis
comme j'ai pas capable de faire l'amour
s'embrasser à ça j'ai pas capable de
m'accepter jugeant j'ai essayé ça fait
25 ans j'essaye de com mais mais mais je
peux capable garde je le fais tu chantes
à 25 ans c'est moi je les fait j'avais
18 ans et concerne pas je me suis
si chris je pourrais juste avoir des
nouveaux centres pis j'en mets 5 serait
beau pays je serai demain mais dans mon
corps mais ce poste parce que la réalité
lui aussi est quelque chose qui me rend
mal à l'aise par rapport aux faits en
iphone c'est que j'ai l'impression que
si c'etait pas lysandre qui avait fait
se met on importe quel autre influence
en avait fait sa star était peut-être
vraiment plus mal perçues - s'est les
choses kim qui me dérange un peu je
voudrais ben pour moi il faut il donner
sa légende c'est que ça soit pas nulle
part dans ce sens que utilisant d'être
chauve et et what you see is what you
get puis andré que ceux ci comme ça pour
ça avec le personnage effet take de
casting pour les gens qui a surfé
justement seront pas vraiment choqué
parce qu'il s'attendait à quelque chose
du genre at il ajouté si mes tantes
était quelqu'un qui tire le public jeune
mais je connaissais personne dix pour
cent des personnes qui ont eu 18 ans
c'est sûr que ça c'est sûr qu'ils sont
cons nuit quand même adulte maxi peut
décemment consommée par juste des
adultes fact et si tu es quelqu'un
justement de kiki foule genre
premièrement j'ai pas le mot qui voit
moins la saison la plus sensible tabou
que ce soit piqué république vraiment
jamais le genre qui sait je comprends
qu'on soit encore plus surpris cela
choqué parce que c'est plate comme sa
puce ce qu'était mois au fond je si j'ai
envie de me certains olyphant vois pas
pourquoi que je pourrai moins qu'ils
hantent [ __ ] a pas que l'impact serait
plus négatif si c'est moi qui suis
certain mon iphone
au final j'ai 25 ans je sais qu'avec mon
corps aussi très mais je pense que je
pense que prévu cette année une foule
marchant je voulais l'annoncer mais je
pense pas que ça serait un scandale
spécial de voir à quel point qui est
fixée et elle sait - puis il ya beaucoup
monkey qui sont montées aux brigades
pour défendre le choix personnel mais
celle ci n'a compté pour faire ce que
pau pour continuer ce que tu dit à dom
qu'elle consent parler mais aussitôt que
j'ai entendu seuil à quelque chose qui
est flashé
je savais pas exactement quoi c'est
écrit dessus et je savais pas quoi mais
y avait quelque chose dans ma tête qui
kibo gueule parce que de monétiser sa
sexualité
il y avait quelque chose dans ce goût ya
quelque chose que je trouvais qu'il
n'était pas en même temps je dors de la
pornographie est excitant des
travailleurs du sexe qui y en a qui font
de leur plein gré les esprits ils
montrent justement qui font de la porn
de leurs grilles ils font de l'argent
avec ce télé où loulou leurs points
faibles
ça y est t'es écoute pillon delà des
d'abord le benson callier de la zotac
situe mal en soi je veux tu être mais
peut-être justement parce que ces gens
là ces gens là sont pas des exemples
pour les jeunes c'est peut-être là que
moi j'ai eu un problème
ces gens-là simcity des lascars ch la
face le justement l'exemple précis que
tu viens de me donner on les voit jamais
et là on sait pas c'est qu'il sait le
canon moi et mes médecins puissent mon
deuil
ils n'ont pas créé un accord quatre
patients qui n'ont pas créé un mode
histoire
ils n'ont pas créé un auditoire de deux
jeunes de 18 à 24 ans payons pas créer
un auditoire de gens qui lisent de
l'entrée de gens qui qui les suivaient
pour parce qu'ils étaient motivés ou
inspirent-ils ces deux à voir comment
différentes de prendre une posture qui
ne fait que se son métier de prendre
quelqu'un qui s'exposent sur internet en
expliquant ses problèmes de coeur
et puis tellement toujours 15 non
plusieurs comme un switch qui était
bizarre dans ma tête
andré les gens qu'il idolâtrait tu sais
je trouve que jamais la pente
je trouve que la pente est glissante
mais même des maisons - exemple que ça
fait huit ans que je suis dix ans puis
je suis fan des routes et pour moi
disant c'est comme si mon idole
maintenant si je vois ce puis je vais
m'abonner à elle je la vois tu menu je
trouve que la perception va
vraiment différents la perception savoir
le lisant on va être rendu vraiment
différente je peux vous le comprenez ce
que je dis moi ça me rendrait très vous
ont vraiment mal à l'aise de savoir que
chez pas et pierre eric et j'ai une
gueule de ses vins qui me suit depuis
hier trois ans doit quitter qui me
voient à pois et mettez dans 10 dans les
potions qui me dit que je me sente
cochon maintenant je me sens belle dit
je prends les belles photos tiges comme
je sais pas si tellement ça s'est
tellement quand même par ce manque et je
voudrais pas que mes abonnés voix et l
as encore je pense oui je suis quelqu'un
vient que de 16 ans qui va voir le pays
et j'ai vu des photos nues après
spéciale fac juste différente de ben
mezrich ce mois jugent pas du tout les
intentions du juge pas du tout les
intentions du temps derrière sur le papa
pantoute le sketch avec coach de la
difficulté si l'effet que ça peut avoir
peut-être seul problème pour - c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être le problème
que ça devienne pis tu le disais bien
tantôt que ça d'une facilité de faire
comme loges
moi aussi je veux voyager tout le temps
voit vraiment d'emplois viva et les
danseurs mais je vais faire tout ce qui
a fait comment je peux faire sur la
crise moi aussi je veux faire payer du
monde pour 1100 après ça c'était photo
le tennis à sa puce partage était de les
enregistrer puis on sait pas l'impact
que cela peut avoir dans la vie d'une
jeune fille qui est au secondaire c'est
maintenant ce soit c'est quelque chose
que je n'ai jamais voulu qui m'arrive le
clic des jeunes lamentin d'attentes ump
tonton petite amie de partage à tous ses
amis que le monde était tellement honte
était mon génie comme les photos de les
en tenue télévores soprano tout ce
qu'elle va mettre là au moment où dit
d'aller mettons chaque fois que vous
portez de quoi dans les heures qui vont
suivre ça va se retrouver le fait et dit
gg je connais les entre personnellement
petit j'allais même d'en monter je reste
je la respecte beaucoup mais nous aussi
sincèrement vraiment vraiment folie si
je pense que c'est normal que ça vienne
choquer mais par leur parce qu'à ce
niveau là je pense qu'on a vraiment pas
les même pas
mais ça n'enlève en rien ce que je pense
à elle enlève rien dans une personne qui
est vraiment peu cynique et si on lui en
sait encore une fonction du sens et puis
on l'a on n'a pas la réponse qui zonent
j'ai pas on dirait que tout ce qui drive
tout ce qu'a fait entre que peu importe
la décision petit prince c'est qu'avec
pis c'est une question qu'il faut se
poser leurs baux évidemment mais est ce
qu est ce qui est peu importe la
décision du prince est correct je vais
prendre l'exemple on en parlait juste
avant que rossi le podcast france alors
qu'on le mans alors l'âme et le corps
coronavirus lyon le le monde qui disent
à un mouvement mouvement crise ça me
fait pas peur
fake moi je veux aller en voyage prendre
l'avion t on le voit beaucoup maintenant
lui comme dépose des mines de jean
oreilles vous dites oh milenio qu'il ya
des vols par sharp une chance de mourir
genre parfait six mois de suite le tir
bien la décision de faire ceux désirant
mais moi je fais ce que je veux
attends un peu parce que ça l'a
peut-être une répercussion qui touchent
pas juste j'ai une grande artiste
dernièrement
ou est-ce que c'est sur le sahara est
présent sur le site web sur le site web
l'égard des peuples africains qu'on voit
dans ce podcast
mais c'était sur l'aim la phrase vivre
et laisser vivre parce que dans toutes
les actions militantes béton qui vont
chez joe beef il ya souvent le monde
qu'en envoyant au tabernacle georgie
respecte les vg mais respecté mon choix
oui ton choix ta liberté du rsa wright
qu'un camier imprimés quelqu'un d'autres
techniques tonnes responsable des sports
et que toutes tes choix entre citoyens
et raviront sans précédent on peut pas
penser de même c'est sûr que non et ce à
tous de nous qui on a même été sur le
web on a une visibilité même projet sur
le web mais c'était une visibilité je
pense qu'il faut tout le temps de guerre
ouais exact mais même au quotidien il
n'est pas vrai que tu peux pas penser de
même c'est impossible puis c'est pour ça
que cette mentalité-là cette attitude
aux affaires mois mais seulement la
pêche parce que je veux que mon corps je
comprends que tu fais ce que tu veux que
ton corps jusqu'à temps que ça impacte
pas quelqu'un d'autre
jusqu'à temps que il ya pas un conflit
qui va se faire bouffer à l'école parce
qu'en sixième
quand sa part regretté georges m'excuse
mais si ça arrive maintenant ce titre e
on sait jamais quel point ça peut avoir
une répercussion négative sur la vie de
quelqu'un mais exemple justement quelle
est la petite fille sans doute et par
exemple mais exemple le pays qui
pourrait arriver une petite fille qui se
dit assez facile je fais c'est
finalement ça des répercussions
négatives sur sa vie parce que là tout
le monde a vu ses notes à l'école puis
entendons bien jean rey a senti dans ses
choix est pas bien puis mettons qu'elle
suicide j'en sais combien je sais que
c'est gros mais ça pourrait tellement
arrivée tester des trucs qui pour ses
pommes au l'imagination de penser à soc
est pas hors de l'imagination plat on
extrapole mais c'est faux quand même y
penser sport de l'imagination pensée
quant à mener il ya eu une jeune femme
qui veut voyager pittis fait offrir par
un goût un peu croche de commettre ce
genre on va les prendre chez nous on va
les prendre des photos et je vois tu
donnais 20 ml pièce pi que tu arrives là
bas puis que c'est pas juste des photos
puis que la finance et 30000 pour de
quoi d'autre piketty ça dans ma tête
c'est vraiment proche de quelque chose
qui pourrait se passer de ses meilleurs
jeux à quel point ça va se passer à quel
point ça va se passer je trouve que
c'est important se pose la question
parce que j'ai l'impression que ce genre
de démarche là comme je disais tout à
l'heure où la ligne transgresse la ligne
quelque chose c'est quelque chose comme
ça arrive tu es malheureusement c'est un
peu ta responsabilité je dirai ce que tu
veux vraiment arrive avec sa conscience
si je sais pas je pense que ça vaut la
peine assez bonne question c'est des
bonnes questions à parler après après
avoir acheté un nouveau conte ferrari
avec des doutes sur internet
merci beaucoup plus c'était vraiment
super bonne sur leur site est ouverte
sur le pote se rend compte en est venu
je suis content d avoir entendu ma belle
voix de moins 100 quelque chose